a bird inspired drone developed by EPFL
uses artificial wings made of fiberglass
covered in nylon which allow for easier
maneuverability in high winds and salto
the leaping robot from UC Berkeley has
the highest robotic vertical jump and
can even wall jump look at salt oh I
love salt Oh Vsauce Kevin here this is
mine kissinger lets you send and receive
kisses through your phone the attachment
features high-precision force sensors
under a silicon lip to measure your kiss
and transmit it to the device on the
kiss receivers phone this actually isn't
a new idea in fact my blow 16 back in
2011 and on Vsauce one and mind blow 46
in 2012 covered prototypes for robot
kissing devices
there was even another device named
kissinger by a company called la phonics
but it looks like this new kissinger
from mixed reality lab is the most
practical yet since it's significantly
more compact and interfaces directly
with your phone BAE Systems envisions a
future where lenses are made with laser
beams controlling hot air bubbles the
laser developed atmospheric lens system
creates lenses by layering hot air
bubbles on colder air using laser pulses
which then refract light this concept is
similar to how current solid lenses made
of plastic or glass work but making one
out of air would allow it to be much
larger and maneuverable this technique
could also be used to deflect laser
attacks by dispersing the beam so
basically like laser beam shields in
sci-fi movies but it's just a concept
for now there is no prototype yet wave
optics is developing wearable augmented
reality technology to overlay computer
graphics on the real world their headset
nicknamed the ghost is designed for
developers and not as a consumer device
and they say they're fully transparent
display creates sharp Holograms with a
wide field of view their
proof-of-concept video shows how this
could be used in work and leisure
scenarios basically getting one step
closer to turning the world into a video
Ikaros is a fitness flying virtual
reality game controller machine the
active VR experience connects wirelessly
to a headset and demands your full body
to control flying through the game
navigating inside the rings requires
shifting your weight and this thing is
more like a futuristic exercise device
than a gaming peripheral alright that's
the last VR story for this episode
okay one more VR story axon VR wants you
to feel virtual reality be half X is a
haptic textile that could provide
vibration tactile and thermal feedback
for feeling virtual shape texture weight
and temperature they claim the range of
touch berries from the brush of a
butterfly's wing to the impact of a
punch and a goal is for their system to
be available in theme parks and arcades
and not likely in your house
unfortunately a soft robotics leave can
restore normal blood flow after heart
failure traditionally a failing heart
has its blood removed and passed through
tubes and pumps which increase the risk
of blood clotting but this new device
works without contacting blood there's
still more work to be done before this
moves on to human trials but soft robot
heart pumping is awesome and I just
wanted to show you so yeah the Sun and
footsteps are all that are needed to
power these new street lights and go
planet installed kinetic tiles in Las
Vegas to help power streetlights Wi-Fi
hotspots video surveillance and USB
ports for mobile device charging the
panel's generate between 4 to 8 watts
from
pedestrian foot traffic and dependent on
the success of this 4 light trial the
plan is to roll out large scale
installations on the Vegas strip and in
new york city parks and chroma art
glasses designed to alleviate red-green
color blindness the lenses feature a
patent-pending multi notch filter which
cut out sharp wavelengths of light to
enhance specific colors and separate the
red and green cones
this helps to counter the overlap
between red and green which affects
those with that form of colorblindness
these allow people for instance to
easily identify the color difference
between a green traffic light and a blue
sky background finally researchers at
Intel labs created an algorithm for
mobile robots to navigate cluttered
environments the quadcopter is able to
reach its goal through this maze and
navigate 200 interwoven strings and 20
poles it's a fun drone obstacle course
unrelieved with large-scale programmable
disassembly of tiny room robots and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
mechanical ear the microphone which is
really a glorified telephone transmitter
the power from the microphones is
amplified about 10 million times by
these vacuum tubes making the voice
current strong enough to operate the
machine that photographs the sound do
you follow me
and then this amplified current is
carried by wires along through the
theater and down to the screen on the
stage to connect with the loudspeaker
this is a typical layout of the stage
set with two horns behind the screen
the receivers connected to the horns
convert the electrical vibrations back
into sound waves exactly the way the
telephone receiver operates so that
while the picture is being shown the
sound which was recorded is reproduced
in step with the pictures the screen is
full of small holes so that the horns
may be placed behind the screen to let
the sound through this gives the
illusion that the sound is coming from
the image of the speaker
Napo illness
[Music]